So it truly saddens me that it's come to this.
But at this point, Dr. Deborah Burtis, one
of the doctors that frequently participates
in Trump's Corona virus, press briefings.
We probably can't trust her anymore.
She's become, sadly, a political tool for
Trump, repeating absolutely unbelievable praise
about Trump that none of us would believe
for even a fraction of a second.
Instead of just telling things like they are,
Dr. Doctor was recently interviewed by the
Christian Broadcasting Network, a disgusting
right wing media outlet.
She seemed to have been lobotomized to two
to pick a slightly hyperbolic term compared
to how she used to talk about what we're dealing
with.
Check this out.
Dr. Deborah Burke's response coordinator for
the White House Corona Virus Task Force.
Long history of working productively in infectious
disease immunology.
She was Obama's global AIDS coordinator.
But slowly but surely, during this corona
virus situation, more and more just deferring
to Trump, pretending like Trump is some kind
of genius with this stuff.
Check out this clip from her CBN interview.
She says Trump is amazing.
He's just a he's analyzing data.
He's integrating that data to make the best
decisions about coronavirus guys.
Trump.
Two days ago said he didn't know whether it
was a flu, a germ or a virus.
Trump admitted yesterday that he learned a
worse case mortality estimate was 2.2 million
deaths.
Yesterday, Trump learned that yesterday.
OK, here is Dr. Burke's functioning almost
like she's had a piece of her brain removed.
How would you describe the job?
President Trump is doing behind the scenes
and in front of the cameras during these daily
briefings that we're seeing.
What's your perspective, Dr. Burke's?
He's been so attentive to the scientific literature
and the details and the data.
And I think his his ability to analyze it,
integrate data that comes out of his long
history and business is really been a real
benefit.
During these discussions about medical issues,
attentive to data, can you imagine Trump's
presidential daily briefings were reduced
from a binder of reports to one page to one
page with just a few bullet points and a couple
of pictures.
Trump can't pay attention to anything.
He has the attention span of a fruit fly.
And Dr. Birks says thanks to Trump's attentiveness
to data, he's really taking the data into
consideration.
Here's more of her interview, because in the
end, data is data and he understands the importance
of the granularity.
And I think he's been really excited about
finding the level of detail that we've been
able to now bring.
Over the last few weeks, to really understand
who is at the greatest risk for severe illness,
who will have mild and less and asymptomatic
disease and really calling on every American
to do that social distancing because some
people may not know they're actually infected
and be unknowingly spreading the virus.
And that all comes from the president seeing
the data and then really directing these policies
in these guidelines that go out to the American
people.
Trump understands the importance of the granularity
and finding a level of detail.
What?
Who is she describing?
It's not even plausibly believable that this
is the trump that this.
This is how Trump is managing this.
The guy learned two days ago about mortality
models that we've had for weeks and weeks.
So for me, this instantly raises major questions
about Dr. Burke's, his trustworthiness.
We know Trump doesn't read ever.
Trump doesn't read, never mind being attentive
to the data.
It's just it's truly incredible garbage.
It's very clear what's going on.
She wants to stay on Trump's good side.
She has learned the only way to do that is
to praise Donald Trump.
He's incompetent.
He's clueless.
He's an existential threat to the country.
But Dr. Burke's has been fully sucked in.
So we've got Dr. Anthony Foushee now.
That's the guy we've had.
We have left.
He clearly is also being very careful not
to get Donald Trump mad at him.
The thing about Foushee is in interviews where
Trump isn't standing next to him, he's a little
bit more of a truth teller.
And here was another non-answer from Dr. Birks
when when when the question was asked.
You know, you've been promising X number of
tests, some huge number.
You've been promising this huge number of
tests for weeks and they're not there.
Here is how Dr. Bourke's answered with one
of these complete non-answer talking point
comas.
We're learning.
I know, you know, last week and bringing the
private sector.
I think what has been exciting to me over
the last two and a half weeks is see this
administration harness the full capacity of
the private sector.
Understanding that a lot of our solutions
that we need to confront this virus lie, rely
on the private sector, bringing the private
sector commercial labs was critical into.
This process we are now beginning to see that
they have spread out in a prioritized way
because we asked them just to prioritize the
regions that were mostly affected.
And so you still may have difficulty getting
tests in areas that do not have significant
cases.
It really makes me sad to say it, but we just
can't really trust Dr. Bourke's anymore to
be giving us the unvarnished medical and scientific
truth.
She's giving us political statements calculated
not to upset Donald Trump.
We need doctors just telling us the truth,
not political people trying to avoid upsetting
Donald Trump.